let's talk about something i've said for
a long time and now it's coming from
inside the house inside the republican
house that is a republican consultant
reportedly working for the pennsylvania
gubernatorial republican candidate doug
mastriano says jews are not welcome in
the conservative movement
well yeah i've been telling you that for
a long time we're going to talk about
this this is a very very interesting
situation that's going on the jerusalem
post reports jews and non-christians are
not part of the conservative movement
according to a republican candidate
consultant
this is about doug mastriano and an
advisor named andrew torba
jews and other non-christians are not
conservative because it is an explicitly
christian movement says andrew torba the
ceo of gab that's a right-wing uh
platform and reportedly a consultant for
state senator doug mastriano who is
indeed the republican candidate for
governor of pennsylvania
masteriano has come into the public eye
in recent weeks after u.s media outlets
reported he spent five grand advertising
on gab that's a social media network
favored by the far right the candidate
has also reportedly paid for campaign
consulting from gab with reports that
new gab users are set to automatically
follow masteriano both republicans and
democrats have called for mastriano to
withdraw his ad
from the social media platform torba
claimed many candidates are running
campaigns on gab although he didn't name
them
um
this is the most important election of
the 2022 midterms because doug is an
outspoken christian said torba
we are going to build a coalition of
christian nationalists of christians of
christian candidates at the state local
and federal levels and we're going to
take this country back for the glory of
god
my policy is not to conduct interviews
with reporters who aren't christian give
me a break
torba called mastriano's opponent josh
shapiro who by the way is jewish a soros
puppet a reference to jewish billionaire
george soros and reiterated claims that
he was involved in voter fraud in the
2020 election this is a christian
movement all right so listen this should
not come as a surprise to anybody in the
audience
one of the most liberal voting groups
is
jews
another very liberal voting group is
black americans and in both cases more
with black americans than with jews
when republicans are confronted with
this fact hey
88 of jews voted for the democrat hey 88
of of black americans voted for the
democrat they go oh they're brainwashed
sometimes they'll say they're on the on
the found what was it they're on the
plantation some of them would say
no
actually it's that jews and black folks
have looked at the two parties
and from the choices have realized oh
voting for democrats is more in line
with our interests it's more logical
republicans don't really seem to like us
very much
and
i've been saying for years when
republicans talk about
judeo-christian values
and this is a judeo-christian country
they don't mean that that's pandering
and it's posturing to make it seem as
though
it's not just christianity that they
care about so when you see people like
ben shapiro
jared kushner uh this guy boris epstein
mark levin the guy from fox news i i
assume he's jewish from from his name
although i don't know for sure these are
essentially useful idiots they love to
say stuff about how
the real racism
the real anti-semitism and all this
stuff is actually on the left now there
is anti-semitism on the left it's
different than the anti-semitism on the
right and i've talked about it before i
don't shy away from that
but they are useful idiots for a
movement
that at the end of the day
only
reluctantly accepts them if they are 100
in line
with the talking points that they are
supposed to repeat useful idiot i know
it sounds like an insult it's a
political term a useful idiot is someone
who ends up propagandizing for a cause
without fully even realizing what the
causes goals are you you're cynically
used by the leaders
and
the vast majority of these
right-wing jews are being cynically used
by the movement we've talked about this
when you've got
gay conservatives and oh well we agree
about low taxes and blah blah blah it
it's very much the same sort of thing
and so i haven't actually seen
what the reaction to this has been
from the right wing juice
my guess is they would say something
like torba doesn't speak for the right
wing movement and i can disagree with
torba
or maybe he was taken out of context or
whatever i don't know that i'm guessing
they would equivocate in some way rather
than saying
man i'm part of a movement that
basically hates me
they're probably not going to just cop
to it in that way
but i've been talking about this for a
very long time and this is just the
reality and whether or not you know the
ad is pulled from gab
doesn't really make a difference about
how jewish folks and many other groups
to be to be clear this particular
stories about jewish folks
are seen by very large swaths of the
right wing movement